Our newfound mastery of environments puts us in a perfect place
to write interpreter code for declaring and calling functions.
However, there's a lot more to functions than just environments.
For example, someone could be a little mean and give us a procedure like this
to try to interpret.
Mean of x immediately returns x, but then after that it has written print
"one thousand and one nights".
We should never actually print out "one thousand and one nights"
from this function definition.
We should return first.
That's a shame because One Thousand and One Nights is perhaps the best-known example
of Arabic literature, a collection of Middle Eastern and South Asian stories.
One of my particular favorite parts are the stories involving Sindbad the Sailor.
Unfortunately, his luck fluctuates wildly.
More on Sindbad perhaps later on.
The meaning of this is we need a way to return without doing any more work.
Let's get a better feel for this with a bit of a puzzle.
Here I've written a bit of Python code, and I have 4 assignment statements involving x.
What I'd like you to do is imagine that these assignment statements are not there.
But you get to add one of them in, and your goal is to try to add in a statement
that will prevent us from printing out "sindbad".
So again, assume these statements aren't there,
but which ones could you move in to prevent "sindbad" from being printed?
Multiple multiple choice. Check all that apply.